a widely viewed video of a baby being
rescued from inside a hot car in Florida
this week is drawing new attention to a
potentially deadly risk a woman spotted
that a little baby and called 911 County
Sheriff's Office released body cam video
of the rescue
yesterday children in Texas and
Connecticut died from overheating in
vehicles that brings the number of hot
car deaths this year to 27 Kris Van
Cleave is in Washington with more on the
story cliff Chris good morning to you
good morning a car parked in the Sun can
see the temperature inside jumped by 20
degrees in just 10 minutes now it's only
about 70 degrees outside here in
Washington today inside the car were up
over 80 almost 85 degrees and where this
gets particularly dangerous will be in
the high heat of the day the high temps
here around 86 could push the
temperature inside the car past a
hundred and forty degrees in Orange City
Florida not far from here we avoided a
disaster
sheriff's deputies received a 911 essica
Kyser Tuesday after she spotted a child
alone in a parked car
Jessica Keizer saw a Nissan Rogue what
they thought was a doll in the back seat
well that doll turned out to be an eight
month old child the child's mother
returned 24 minutes later
outside had that woman had Jessica
Kaiser not come out and been observant
like that we would have been discussing
a tragedy of an eight month-old child
Susan Auriemma is vice president of the
advocacy group kids in cars org we've
seen scenarios so many times where
parents believe they dropped off at
daycare and in fact they continued
straight on to work and the child was
left alone in the vehicle for the entire
day the group says 27 children have died
after being left in a hot car compared
to 43 last year on average 37 kids died
nationally Auriemma says it's not
uncommon for parents to lose awareness
of their children in the car it's a
mistake to think it can't happen to you
and not take measures to prevent
children from being left alone in a
vehicle all right now that mom has been
arrested she's facing child neglect
charges she told police that she thought
she had dropped her kid off at her
father's house the kid is expected to be
ok fionna thankfully Chris thank you we
appreciate it